I don't even know how to intro this one
but I had to bring in help so the first
teaser trailer for venom finally came
out and I was not in the mood to rush
this out to get it my reaction the same
day that the trailer came out I did it
for Deadpool I'm not doing it for this
but turned out this guy actually wanted
to talk about this as well so we have
Ryan Daly joining us today hi folks I
this was my idea and yet as soon as you
agree to it I was like I don't have
anything does to say well why did I
suggest this alright well this is your
one good night from yeah okay so yeah oh
boy where do we even start okay I mean
I've talked about this movie before and
pretty much I've been highly skeptical
from the beginning because I think a
venom movie in and of itself is a
dubious prospect making it without
spider-man even more so but I when it
was announced that was gonna be an
r-rated horror film I had a sliver of
hope because I thought okay if you go
say body horror if you really ramped up
the notion of what this thing is doing
to his mind and his body and him
fighting with it and you go are maybe I
wasn't like this will work I was like
there is a there was a tiny little
there's a tiny bull's eye yeah if they
could if they could just get but it's a
tiny bull's eye surrounded by just a
world of suck so this trailer makes me
think they did not hit that huh I don't
know what this trailer shows well that's
part of the problem I I'm sure we'll get
into that but I mean I I rewatched it a
little bit ago and I found myself asking
questions that there are no answers to
and and I don't just mean what is venom
look like I mean just within the context
of it as a trailer in and of itself
there's a guy in the hospital why we
don't know
we started hearing voice over is it the
voice of the guy who we saw we don't
know there's talk of an accident we see
something what kind of accident was this
we don't know like there is a whole
bunch of we don't know basically unless
you know the name venom there's really
nothing to go on
from this which was my my overall
impression is if they did not give you
that title card at the end of this
preview this could be anything anything
my brother even joked it's like
firestarter too it's like sort of
paranormal sci-fi conspiracy thriller
it's like could be the astronauts life
it could be something like weird it's
it's it's it's not so specific it's
basically is so generic so broad even
the voiceover I actually I turned it on
I just closed my eyes and listen to the
voice or which is do we think it is Tom
Hardy doing the voice-over doing an
American accent because I think it is
now III might have to go back and check
maybe they had mike tyson to the
voice-over terrence howard oh it's it's
got it it's at it's pitched at a weird
sort of level and it's got this tiny
little hint of a lisp and I was also
dialogue that means nothing Erik eighth
grade poetry writing it's awful so you
look like that happen combination like
it almost looks like a parody commercial
for an action movie it's like there's a
guy wearing pajamas like he's escaped
from the hospital riding a motorcycle in
the city there's black SUVs exploding
around those like you know there's
literally one shot of black goop in a
container yeah again like if it didn't
say venom I wouldn't know that this is a
comic book movie let alone and and
you're right like I kind of come from
the same place like the prospect of a
venom movie is not enticing to me
because I don't really like that
character as a protagonist I like him as
a spider-man villain even then he is not
one of my favorites by the men zones but
I think it is a particular niche as a
protagonist it just as an interest to me
however as you've said if they make a
beam if they make changes to get rid of
spider-man so you're changing his origin
you're tweaking a little bit so he's not
a derivative character now you can still
do that and make a good sci-fi horror
movie and there's a chance that it will
be it still doesn't appeal to me but I'm
just one fan that doesn't mean it's not
going to be a good movie there were good
movies that I don't necessarily like so
it's possible but like I look at this
one like who looks at this preview and
just like I'm excited for a venom
because there's nothing about venom in
that's like oh and I think that's a big
big now I've I've said this and actually
this kind of almost springboards off
something I said when I did my video
talking about Deadpool which is right I
I feel like the people making these
trailers are making them as if we still
lived in a world where the first place
people were gonna see movie trailers
isn't a movie thing it was in a theater
in front of another movie or maybe in a
TV spot or whatever like it would stop a
Super Bowl yeah the trailer would start
they wouldn't already know what it is
Deadpool did that to a certain to read
this one really does that and I it still
wouldn't be a good trailer but I think
it would play better if if you weren't
sure what it wasn't then by the end you
end oh it's venom but we don't live in
that world we live in a world where the
vast majority of people who see this
trailer clicked on a video link that
said venom official teaser trailer and
by the end of it you're going where the
hell was venom I agree with that except
to the point where I think that basic
premise of introducing a trailer where
the audience doesn't know what they're
going to see is they're basically coming
in cold and they get that final reveal
at the end I think that plays into a
certain degree of mystery and like a
mystery or a whodunit after you get the
reveal at the end you can backtrack and
say oh these were the clues these were
the things leading up to it even if it's
a minute and a half typically that's the
way that sensation would play out if
that was the emotion they were going for
this does not need any breadcrumbs
that's the no there are no clues seated
in this
it's just kinda I was looking to cuz
like there's that he mentions an accent
there's this shot of this thing like get
him I don't know if it's a horse or a
field or what it is but they were like
these strands coming out it was like is
that webbing but then I look closer it's
like no I could see cable hookups
they're just cables I don't know what
any of this like and he's in the lab
being skinned for some way I don't I
mean well I'm assuming they're going
with the he has cancer version of his
origin which didn't Deadpool just do
that and probably did it better like
taiga we've got our it's an r-rated
antihero with cancer as his backstory
and that leads to him getting
superpowers yeah kind of I don't know
and what I think it was a very poor idea
for them to play coy with any image of
venom himself because I have anyone else
has been vocalizing this up to this
point I think plenty of people are
saying it now with the trailer I'm but
I've been thinking with the various you
know images from production that have
come out or things that have been
tweeted from said or whatever that we
have seen no hint of what venom looks
like no concept art no concept art no no
previous no nothing we have no clue and
that's what everyone who cares about
this character is dying to find out
because then you strip away most of what
venom he's kind of a look it's the it's
the design of the character that people
care about I mean like what do you like
venom or not he starts with a visual
concept and then you basically reverse
engineer or a character from there he's
spider-man as a monster he's that's that
was the starting point that it was like
how do we justify this yeah but the the
whole thing is just really weird to me
that at this point it really looks like
they are hiding this so hard like they
don't want to show it at all at least
that's how it's reading and it I know
that they're hoping that it's got to be
like we're teasing you like no
everyone's asking how will this look cuz
last time he was on film
he didn't look good right so we want to
know that he
looks good we can't do this trailer and
you know give him to us and I'm also
actually a pretty concerned about this
version of Eddie Brock and I have been
for a while because like I remember the
first image of him that got published
he's like got all these tattoos and
everything I'm like so it's no longer
any Brock former crusading reporter it's
now Eddie Brock bar biker guy like what
oh I don't understand I was I was
comparing this comparing the character
of venom to Deadpool in terms of their
fandom and they both came about in the
early 90s they were both largely based
on a visual appeal and a visual look and
they kind of berry they were anyway so
they they were very popular in the early
90s then there was a backlash associated
with the character specific to were kind
of tied into the backlash of comic books
from the 90s maybe you know something
about that
oh maybe have maybe a little might have
some experience
the thing was Deadpool found some
Redemption and that he had a second life
within five or ten years of that
character kind of like fittingly he was
resurrected reinvented repurposed to be
this fourth wall breaking homicidal in
Petryk stir what kind of a character and
and that plays into what they don't
movie I don't know that venom has ever
gotten that second life he's never
really gone away
no he fanbase clamoring for a venom
movie I don't think is what the studio's
think it is I think you might be onto
something
baron and that's not me sending saying
venom has no fans I'm sure he does but I
mean he he didn't have a second wind his
room peak and popularity was basically
in the 90s with his initial creation
pushing him as a spider-man villain
giving him a string a miniseries doing
carnage but then by say 98 certainly by
2000 people kind of burned out on him
and by that point they started jumping
to sin bio from host to host a host
right which was you the the the current
beneath the
thing doesn't really matter that much
for them yeah so or I'm not gonna say it
doesn't matter I'm gonna say that Mara
that was one of the ways Marvel tried to
revitalize the character by having it
jump host several times they did agent
venom for a while and none up none of it
has stuck so it it's been odd from the
beginning that Sony has kind of latched
on to this character for a solo film so
hard I guess just because he's I suppose
the only spider-man character within the
all the stuff that they have the rights
to make movies to who has ever been a
solo comic-book lead because I don't
think any of the others had I don't
think black cat has ever had her own
title I mean they're just part of teams
yeah well and so I'd that's probably
what they're pairing with silver sable
but like I I feel like this wasn't
driven by an actual analysis of this
character it was driven by of all these
characters we have the rights to who
else had a solo title venom will do
venom I would be even more sickle and
say who else appeared on the most
t-shirts and tattoos okay yeah I'm on my
birthday cake when I was 13 how do you
feel about that today I have no regrets
all right good good and you know what
I'm even worse I always like to carnage
more than venom and carving this is the
derivative with no value just nothing
he's all just surface okay carnage
carnage is the simpler taking over the
Joker that's what carnage yes although
oddly he seems to have had a resurgence
I've actually had a fair number of
people tell me that carnage is stuff
that's gone on lately has been really
good I haven't read it I can vouch for
that but I haven't had people telling me
that about venom I've had people telling
me that about garnish so he might
actually have been a better bet to be
very answer to Deadpool than venom was
but she's supposedly in this so maybe
they're hoping to spend him off later I
mean he did have his own series he did
up here and he venom had his own stories
that went on after spider-man I can't
speak to their quality I still think
he's a character that really has one
story and it is as
as a a foil to spider-man and
spider-man's kind of dilemma when you
give him his own stick he's just a he's
just a killer vigilante yeah and he's
the Punisher with the with the weird
alien suit instead of guns right and I
still didn't get that from the street no
I mean at this point we've devolved just
into talking about the concept cuz
there's really nothing to say about this
trailer no there is it and there's
nothing but if I'm taking a broader
approach like we've we've talked about
it's been kind of in the public
discussion in terms of these pop culture
movies and things like that the notion
of superhero fatigue man will that ever
kick in and I think I think movies like
this that are just kind of generic yeah
might hurt the brand I don't think as
long as you've got movies like whatever
the Avengers franchise coming out that
as long as those continue to be strong I
think they will remain unaffected but I
think a movie like this that's not
Marvel stories that's not Disney or
Warner Brothers hurts these other kind
of like certain third or fourth tier
projects of course now I mean Fox we
have no idea what they're well we know
kind of what their future is in the
short term yeah I think we said like
this isn't a good look for Sony which
has already had a number of black eyes
and we've talked about it in the past
that I I think I was surprised that Fox
sold off their film and entertainment
division before some he did yeah yeah
I'm between between because I we were
talking about this earlier today I said
within five years there's no way Sony
doesn't unload its it's entertainment
debate sure and we thought that five
years ago I remember was your well
you're going we had this discussion we
were going to see the IMAX preview for
guardians of the galaxy yes we 2014 I
think we were talking about when is Sony
just gonna give up the ghost on their
movies and everything and just say all
we're gonna do is build like
Playstations
yeah but Playstations and TV
and cameras yeah I don't know but so
yeah they're just it just really isn't
much I have no place to see this movie
this did I I wasn't really excited for
it in the first place and this didn't
make me want to I think the kik are the
only way I mean I I still might see it
out of pure morbid curiosity and yes I
recognize that makes me part of the
problem cuz I think it'll be bad and I
will pay money anyways I recognize that
but I live in a town that has four
dollar matinees so I'm not paying much
but in any case like the only way that
they can recover from this is next
trailer to show off venom himself and he
looks good now they still blew the first
impression because you only get one
first impression run that will be damage
control if they can pull that off and I
find that questionable yeah so I think
that's probably all we have to say about
the venom teaser trailer I don't know
why I got out of bed for this yeah it
was your idea better than any idea Paul
would have had okay that's true so
Ryan's got a whole bunch of podcast
stuff that he does battle be down in the
description links for that I'll decide
which one I'm gonna end up plugging for
that if you like my stuff you can do all
those things that people do support me
on patreon there's merch their swag
there's buttons you can follow me on
Twitter I got a podcast again links down
in the description so until next time
Adam this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]